sur le terrain quand on accompagne donc
les personnes à la création d'activités
c'est que la première entrée c'est la
recherche de subventions donc l'aide
c'est est perçu comme une finalité non
pas comme un moyen d'atteindre un
objectif donc l'idée c'est de les
accompagner à structurer le projet
avancer par étape et à lever les
contraintes qu'il peut avoir sur la
création d'activités sachant que les
contraintes peuvent être un peu plus
compliquées dans les haut de par donc de
caractéristiqu géographique historique
et sociologique de ce territoire loin
éloignement de la clientèle une
clientèle plus difficile à capter des
déplacement plus long plus contrat un
foncier économique plus limité avec des
activités qui sont souvent domicile donc
avec des peu de perspectives de
développement face à tous ces freins la
solution ça serait de faire autrement
euh d'innover de mutualiser les moyens
euh de s'ouvrir aux autres d'échanger
beaucoup sur ces réseaux en connaissant
et en connectant avec d'autres chefs
d'entreprise en partageant les
expériences c'est par ces échanges que
le projet peut s'enrichir qu'on peut
peut-être s'entraider développer des
collaborations développer de la
solidarité si on a un projet allez-y
partout